vision has no problem transforming into
a 50s tv husband
but things weren't quite so easy for
paul bettany and wanda vision's makeup
department
disney's new series easily zips between
decades
but a lot of genius costume makeup and
set design went into recreating famous
sitcoms and giving them the perfect
mcu twist you won't believe the colors
the team had to use to film those black
and white scenes
vision had to take on an entirely new
hue i'm sorry
here's the wardrobe and makeup magic
that went on behind the scenes
paul bettany had to wear vision makeup
six days a week
and although he says it wasn't difficult
to put on taking it off was an entirely
different story
it took more than an hour to remove the
makeup and the actor described it as
feeling like his skin was
in tatters to try and save his skin
betany started spending 20 minutes in a
mobile sauna
every day after filming it loosened the
makeup
and allowed it to be peeled off without
taking any of his skin with it
and it's a pretty relaxing way to
decompress after work
that pain will roll over the earth
seeing the black and white sets in color
makes us realize just how much work went
into making those gray scale
scenes pop on our tv lots of blues and
purples were used to get the hues to
look just right
costume designer mayas rubeo even took
pictures of potential outfits
using the black and white filter on her
phone to see how they'd look on screen
this also meant that vision's red skin
had to go
because it showed up way too dark on
film instead they painted his face
blue to achieve the right contrast well
we could rather do that
catherine hahn brings the perfect amount
of wit and mystery to the character of
agnes
hello dear i'm agnes your neighbor to
the right
but filming the black and white scenes
were hard for her and the rest of the
cast
for a surprising reason it was way too
hot on set the show used lighting
techniques that were accurate for the
era
but they were also extremely warm pair
that with the thick costumes and live
studio audience
and han was spending most of the episode
trying not to sweat through her dress
but despite the heat filming the 50
scenes ended up being one of her
favorite on-set memories do you set your
jellies here
with all of these fashion
transformations it was also important
for the actors to learn how to properly
wear the clothes
we don't mean how to put them on but how
to carry themselves and even speak
differently while wearing them
elizabeth olsen opened up about how
challenging it was to capture the
personalities of women in those specific
eras through their fashion
from the more restrictive style in the
50s to the more relaxed vibe of the 70s
the cast even attended a sitcom boot
camp where they learned how to walk
talk and act like retro characters
really try to make everything very error
specific
elizabeth olsen loved to collaborate on
wanda's sitcom costumes
especially because she spent time on the
set of full house with her sisters when
she was a kid
when it comes to that iconic scarlet
witch costumes from the comics
olsen was the one fighting for it to be
as comic accurate as possible
she convinced the showrunners to go full
out with their halloween tribute to the
original scarlet witch
and maize rubeo made sure all the colors
were bright and accurate
right down to comic wanda's original
pink tights
this is what our show is going to be
about for one division vision's
halloween costume received the same
attention
the green and yellow look complete with
a huge fake mind stone
is an homage to how he looked in the
avengers number 57
all the way back in 1968. there are
reasons marvel finally went for the
costumes now and not before
for one the halloween episode meant the
costumes could purposefully look cheap
and simple
and two before they didn't have the
rights to the character's original
costumes
but now that disney owns fox those
copyright issues are behind them
we can't reverse death one of maya's
rubello's favorite characters to dress
was geraldine monica
especially her groovy 70s style one of
the aspects that her
and actress tiana paris wanted to
include was a natural afro
this allowed them to represent black
culture in a typically white centric
sitcom world
to get inspired to play a sitcom version
of monica rambo
paris took cues from characters like
thelma and willowna in good times
and we can look forward to some more
interesting fashion moments from monica
in the future
rubeo promises that the character will
appear in more wild and surprising looks
before the series is through
i'm a geraldine
mayas rubeo designed wanda's wedding
dress herself
and made it entirely from scratch if it
looks like a familiar old hollywood
style
that's because it definitely is it pays
homage to audrey hepburn
specifically her dress from 1957's funny
face
visions outfits also got to pay tribute
to some television royalty
for episode 1 rubeo took a lot of
inspiration from the dick van dyke show
and designed a suit and tie from scratch
for paul bettany
the actor thought it was so unique and
comfortable that he wanted to take it
home after filming
excellent plan elizabeth olsen's hair
had to endure a lot of transformations
meant to resemble looks from some of the
greatest leading ladies in the history
of sitcoms
the styles are often a mix of different
eras because the aim wasn't to have them
be as
accurate as possible but rather create
over-the-top styles that fit into
wanda's fantasy world
in episode 1 we see 50's curls
reminiscent of isle of lucy
while episode 2 was heavily inspired by
bewitched and the mary tyler moore show
when it came to the 70s it was all about
crazy wild colors
so there was no better show to use for
inspiration than the brady bunch
the set design and wardrobe department
worked together to coordinate wallpaper
paints and fabric that would go well
together and resemble sets of 70 sitcoms
wanda's look was also heavily inspired
by donna from that 70s show
especially the straight red hair by
pulling from a show that aired in the
90s
rubeo and her team were able to keep
wanda's look modern
while not skimping on the outrageous 70s
fashion
it was a challenge for elizabeth olsen
to transform from superhero
to newlywed to new mom but she had
fashion that emulated famous tv moms
from the 80s to help get her into
character
her plaid prints were inspired by shows
like roseanne
while the curly messy hair is
reminiscent of family ties
olsen definitely looks frazzled but
capable and the chaotic 80s styling was
a perfect time to introduce the
character to motherhood
i have everything under control getting
all these looks right was difficult
but by focusing on prints and
silhouettes rubeo was able to capture
and modernize the different decades of
tv fashion
designs were often inspired by specific
colors or types of fabric
the dress wanda wore in the 70s was
inspired by one piece of vintage fabric
that rubeo found and knew she needed to
use
there was only 30 meters available so
she turned it into a simple dress that
could accommodate wanda's growing belly
and also perfectly complement her hair
the result is one of the series most
iconic looks
your personal best with in-depth styling
also comes meticulous attention to every
small detail that might take us
out of the decade we're supposed to be
experiencing the wardrobe and makeup
department had to pay attention to even
the tiniest things
like the length of the actor's
fingernails and their shape
to the different types of fake eyelashes
wanda would be wearing
the 50s showed us short clean nails and
eyelashes perfect for batting across the
dinner table
yes going from black and white to full
color
isn't just a shtick to reel in old
sitcom fans
it's also a way to represent wanda's
inner conflict of being both an avenger
and a grieving woman chasing a
picture-perfect life
this is why it was important for
wardrobe and set designers to create the
most
colorful world imaginable as soon as the
show transitions from black and white
wanda wears a lot of reds or similar
colors
and it's entirely on purpose the black
and white wanda was further distance
from reality but as color comes back and
the story progresses
we see more of the true scarlet witch
what which one division decade is your
favorite
we're big fans of the fun 70s vibe but
we'd also love to watch an entire
bewitched remake starring elizabeth
olsen
let us know your thoughts in the
comments don't forget to hit that like
button and subscribe for more
thanks for watching